the barrios of on Duras and indeed all
of central america are home to vicious
gangs endemic domestic abuse and utter
poverty people scratch out a living to
survive here many resort to crime but
the crimes are committed within these
communities there is no escape
the gangs allowed us inside without
their permission it's impossible we're
being watched
all the time you just don't know by who
virtually every house we pass we're told
as a story of remarkable violence gang
murders are common
what's striking though is the sheer
number of women being killed for being a
woman
it's called femicide and it's out of
control
we were taken through a house of
corrugated sheets and wood heading to
meet the surviving victims of this
femicide epidemic they're really pretty
much on their own now Lloret Rosalinda
and Isaac's mother was murdered by their
stepfather their uncle took them in and
he was murdered relations help them as
much as they can but this little boy is
the one who protects his sister and
brother all they have is this photograph
of their mum it keeps them going what
effect living through your mother's
murder has on such little ones is
difficult to gauge the Durrett has a
burning desire for revenge their
mother's picture is always with them the
photos melody no I wasn't talking to you
do you beminat Karissa okay okay yeah
give me a micrometer
the femicide problem combined with the
random murder of the woman's children is
partly due to the crime gangs and
poverty but it's also part of a culture
that categorizes women as basically
disposable items rich or poor it makes
no difference
women are not even second-class citizens
[Music]
Lillian was beaten to a pulp by upon the
police wanted money to help and they
wanted her sister for sex now she says
she's tough and as a survivor
no more tears I asked her to tell us
what it's like being a woman in Honduras
Honduras a no recuerdo meaning yes banco
de una Hinton we mill the de un pueblo
de me mama vo your legs here yeah la
mujer is starvin maka yeah petechia Mira
que me mama VI Valencia entonces como
que yo Chi yang sick lo la mujer que en
la lucha yo se que en este pais karaim
au coeur MO real go pero cuando no meat
mo en esta noche estamos de puesta
Central America is one of the most
dangerous places to be a woman on earth
a religiously conservative society
offers them little protection
if these very young girls already
pregnant can wish for anything for their
babies is that their father protects
them well they have a boy who at least
has a chance mr. Ramsay skynews Honduras